donald trump salpicado por una nueva
polémica según la revista the atlantic
el presidente canceló su viaje al
cementerio cerca de parís en 2018
rehusándose a honrar las tumbas de los
militares estadounidenses que murieron
en la primera guerra mundial por
considerarlos perdedores y fracasados
según el artículo trump temía que la
lluvia de aquel día dañará su peinado el
presidente lo niega
no es una historia falsa escrita por una
revista que probablemente no va a durar
mucho más pero fue una historia
totalmente falsa y eso fue confirmado
por muchas personas que estaban allí es
terrible que alguien pueda decir ese
tipo de cosas especialmente yo porque he
hecho más por los militares que nadie
atacó a la revista a la que acusó de
publicar para buscar relevancia este
capítulo se convirtió en una contienda
electoral para el candidato demócrata
joe biden la publicación demuestra que
trump no es apto para el cargo de
presidente
se trata de un tema personal de su hijo
fallecido sirvió en las fuerzas armadas
déjenme ser claro cuando mi hijo fue
fiscal auxiliar y voluntario para ir a
kosovo en medio de la guerra como un
civil él no era un fracasado y de bien
cuando mi hijo se unió al ejército de
eeuu como fiscal general para ir a irak
por un año ganó la estrella de bronce y
otros honores no era un fracaso
james jones y guasones shock la visita
del cementerio es un dolor de cabeza que
vuelve para trump pues cuando en 2018
anunció que no iría a honrar las tumbas
la presión pública fue tal que tuvo que
retractarse y asistió al día siguiente